a tragic story here overnight more
bodies were pulled from the waters off
the California coast where a dive boat
burst into flames and sank the US Coast
Guard says the death toll is at least 25
nine people are still unaccounted for
Jonathan Vigliotti is at the Coast Guard
Station in Oxnard California some 30
miles from where the boat sank Jonathan
what do we know about the victims and
good morning to you hours before that
fire broke out three of the victims
celebrated their birthday one of them a
teenage girl
surrounded by her parents one of the
crew members who escaped said he left
behind his girlfriend most of the
victims were trapped just below deck we
are learning some of their body showing
signs of drowning the boat Concepcion
was anchored just 20 yards off the
Channel Islands near the Ventura
coastline when it caught fire according
to the Coast Guard the first mayday call
came in around 3:30 in the morning the
Coast Guard launched aircraft as well as
boats and located a vessel that was
fully involved in flames the 75 foot
vessel carried dozens of divers on a
holiday excursion when the fire began
many passengers were asleep in their
bunks below deck
the ship's blueprint indicates stairs
leading to the main deck at the front of
the vessel authorities say the company
operating the boat had a good safety
record the crew was actually already
awakened on the bridge and they jumped
off five crew members swam to a nearby
fishing boat owned by Bob and Shirley
Hansen flames and knowing that there are
people on board that cannot get out you
can only imagine a horror that they were
going through
they pulled the crew members to safety
including the ship's captain who told
them a rear escape hatch was engulfed in
fire and the crew could do nothing to
help the passengers one crew member was
inconsolable telling them three
passengers were celebrating birthdays
including a 17 year old there with her
parents he was crying
because he knew they were stolen and
then then the one of the crewmen his
girlfriend was was also on board and she
was down there for family members
arriving at the harbour the reality of
this tragedy still wrong are some
absolute heartbreak the NTSB is headed
here to the scene they will be assisted
by the FBI and officials tell us that
boat is upside down it is unstable under
60 feet of water Tony that is
complicating efforts to recover the rest
of those that were trapped inside all
right Jonathan thank you very much